esta es la primera vez que el presidente
duque es tan contundente con eeuu a la
hora de solicitar más esfuerzos dentro
de esa nación para frenar el consumo de
drogas qué medidas pueden implementar
desde el gobierno o bailén para lograr
esta meta
pues el gobierno de bailén necesita
invertir mucho más en reducir la demanda
a través principalmente de programas de
tratamiento a la rehabilitación de
adictos que es una población bastante
enferma que necesita esa atención
normalmente en eeuu hay mucha demanda
para esa rehabilitación pero hay listas
de espera porque hay falta de fondos que
alcance real tendría una reducción de
consumo dentro de eeuu en la producción
en colombia
pues probablemente tendría un extractor
dijeron honestamente la droga principal
que produce colombia es la cocaína
cuya demanda en eeuu no es enorme en
este momento en eeuu tenemos problemas
mucho más graves con drogas sintéticas
como 30 nilo o metanfetaminas pues estos
niños ahora comentan por joe supondría
30 por ciento o tal vez un poco menos de
la demanda mundial para la cocaína
entonces si estados unidos redujera a
esa demanda sería importante pero no
sería determinante para colombia a
finales de octubre eeuu anunció una
nueva estrategia de lucha contra las
drogas en colombia centrada en la
reducción de la producción el desarrollo
en zonas rurales y también la protección
del medio ambiente con qué estrategias
concretas se logran estos tres objetivos
pues eso es el objetivos que además con
in carmen tiene que ver mucho más con
incrementar la presencia del estado
colombiano en vastas zonas rurales donde
hay muy poca presencia la del estado
donde los que viven y casi nunca ven a
un miembro de su gobierno que no lleva
uniforme y arma y apenas en esos casos
en esos entornos es bastante fácil
sembrar la coca a poner laboratorios o
vivir bajo el poder de grupos armados
financiados por el narcotráfico
gobernar el territorio sin impunidad es
tal vez el reto principal para colombia
en esta parte del siglo 21 es parte del
acuerdo de paz con las farc del año 2016
y realmente eeuu lo que nos va en
generación debe ser un eje principal
para los programas de ayuda de eeuu en
vez de mandar a equipos para erradicar
matas de coca que fácilmente se siembran
de nuevo